this new year many in belgrade are
choosing carefully what they put in
their food baskets
and that's because prices have soared
vegetables alone are up 20 percent on a
year ago
we have to predict prices to get to the
end of the month to go through the month
without any debt
we don't eat what we want but what we
have
i managed to put it together somehow to
pay for utilities to pay for electricity
to make ends meet but many probably fail
according to the un global food prices
rose by 30 in the past year hitting the
highest level in almost a decade
that's because harvests have been hit
hard in major exporting countries
including russia the us and canada and
that's partly due to bad weather
disruptions to supplies due to covet 19
factory closures and high energy costs
are also to blame
in serbia prices rose by 7.5 percent but
food was more than double that
oils and fats rose by 22.5 percent
vegetables more than 20 fruit nearly 17
and meat by 14.
it seems to me that this wave will
continue it will not stop at the end of
this year on the contrary i think we
will have a new wave of price increases
and there are several reasons for that
the first is that all excise products
will increase in january there will also
be an energy crisis and this madness
with the prices of gas electricity so on
in november the government capped food
prices of sugar oil flour pork and milk
but that will expire at the end of
january
obviously
objectively this freezing of the prices
of these foods didn't have any effect on
stabilizing prices it had a
psychological impact on consumers and
gave the impression that the government
is protecting the standard of living
many here say price rises far exceed
minimum wage increases and that's
putting pressure on many people to put
food on the table
laura burden manly al jazeera